now conditional probability will let us
explain a lot of the confused arguments
that people brought up about Monty Hall
and we'll see that it is a little bit
confusing and where there are some
correct sounding arguments that give you
the wrong answer so let's go back and
look at our Monty Hall tree that allowed
us to derive the sample space in
probability space for the whole process
of the content the prize being placed in
the contestant picking a door and Carol
opening a door now this tree was way
more complicated than we needed if what
we weren't trying to do was figure out
the probability of winning if you switch
but having the tree will allow us to
discuss a whole bunch of other events
and their probabilities that will get us
a grip on some of the arguments that
gave the wrong answer so let's look at
the event first of all that the goat is
a - now this is the branch where the
prize is it - and so on all the other
branches the goat is it - which means
that we have these eight of the twelve
outcomes in the event goat is it - now
let's also look at the event that the
prize is at one that's just this branch
of the tree okay
so one of the arguments is that when the
contestant is at the point where they've
seen that the open door and they're
trying to decide whether it's tickets or
switch um
they know that the goat is at door to
say without loss of generality that that
was the door that they got to look at
behind with it Carol open and so we want
to ask the probability a given that he
picked one what's the probability that
the prize is at 1 given that the goat is
it - that means that if you're at door 1
then you should a stick if that
probability is high and otherwise you
shouldn't stick so we can look at this
event the prize at one given the goat it
- and what we can see is that it's
taking up exactly half of the outcomes
for go
two and the same kind of outcomes red
ones and green ones the red ones of the
worth in 18th and the green ones are
worth a ninth in probability and that
implies that the probability that the
prizes at one given that the goat is it
two is a half it really is and that's
the argument that people were saying
they said look when the contestant sees
that the goat is at door - and they're
trying to decide whether the goat the
prizes at the door is it door one or at
the other door and it's equally likely
and so it doesn't matter whether they
stick or switch that's a correct
argument but it's not calculating the
probability of the stick strategy
winning why well because there's more
information that's available then goat
is it to the contestant not only knows
that the goat is it - in trying to
figure out the probability that the
prizes it won whether the contestant
knows what door he picked so let's
suppose that the contestant did pick
door one and learn that the goat was at
door - that's a different event if the
the blue one is marked off other places
where the contestant picks one this is
where the door is picked is one and
here's one and here's one this one
splits into one event this one splits
into one event but this choice of one
splits into two outcomes and so when we
look at the event that both the goat is
it - and the contestant picked one which
is what the contestant really knows when
they get to see that there's a goat at
door - we wind up with the overlap of
just three outcomes two outcomes that
have probability 1/8 and one outcome
that has probability a ninth it's just
those three and the result is that the
probability that the prize is at 1 given
that you picked one and the goat is it -
yeah so this is the event goat at 2 and
picked one these three outcomes the
prizes at 1 is these two outcomes which
are
if each worth an 18th and this is an
outcome that's worth a 9th so the prize
at one outcomes amount the half of the
total probability of this event coded to
picked it once so again the probability
that the prizes at 1 given that the
contestant picked one and saw the goat
at 2 is a half also that's confusing so
it seems as though the contestant may as
well stick because at the point that he
has to decide whether to stick or switch
and he knows where the and he sees where
the goat is and he knows what door he's
picked on it's 50/50 whether he should
stick or switch the probability that the
prizes at door 1 that he picked is 1/2
so it really doesn't matter if he stays
there if he decides to switch to the
unopened door but wait a minute it's not
right because the contestant not only
knows what dwarfee picked not only knows
that there's a goat behind a given door
that carol has opened but he knows that
carol has opened that door that's how he
got to know that the goat was there so
let's go back and look at the tree what
basically the previous two arguments are
conditioning on the wrong events
it's a typical mistake and one that you
really have to watch out for so if you
use the correct event what we're looking
at is the contestant knows that they've
picked door 1 that's the and the
outcomes of pick door 1 or marked here
in addition the contestant will get to
know for example in a play of the game
that carol has opened door to carol
opening door 2 is quite a different
event from the goat being it - this is a
picture of the outcomes in Carol opening
door - and we're interested in the
intersection of them that is just this
guy that's in both and this guy that's
in both of there they are and so what we
can do is identify that the event that
you picked one and the carol open door -
consists simply of two outcomes one or
an 18th and one
worth a ninth now at these two outcomes
which one has the prize at one well only
that one remember the first component
here is where the prize is and so the
prize at one event among the given
picked one and open two is just this red
outcome now the red outcome has
probability one 18th and the marina
outcome has probability that's twice as
much so that means that relative to this
event the probability that the prizes at
one given that you picked one and open
two is actually one eighteenth over one
eighteenth plus 1/9 or one third so
given that you picked one and you get to
see what Carol did the probability that
the prize is that the door you picked is
only one-third which means that if you
stick you only have a one-third chance
of winning you should switch and if you
do you'll have a 2/3 probability of
winning so when we finally condition on
everything that we know which is the
contestant knows what door he picked and
what you are Carol opened then we
discover that incorrectly as we deduced
previously that the probability of
switching wins is two-thirds so we're
not trying to read arrive the fact that
the probability of switching wins is 2/3
we're trying to illustrate a very basic
blunder that you have to watch out for
which is when you're trying to reason
about some situation and you condition
on some event that you think summarizes
what's going on if you don't get the
conditioning event right you're going to
get the wrong answer so it's easy to see
how many people got confused and in fact
finding the right event can be tricky
when in doubt the false that are the
four step method with constructing the
tree where you're not even thinking
about probable probabilities but you're
just examining the individual outcomes
is a good fallback to avoid these kinds
of confusing situations